IT'S TIME FOR TONIGHT'S HASHTAG
WAR.
BAM.
I'M GOING TO GIVE YOU GUYS A
HASHTAG AND I WANT YOU TO BUZZ
IN WITH AS MANY TWEETS THAT FIT
THE HASHTAG.
IN HONOR OF THE NEW X-MEN
TRAILER COMING OUT TONIGHT'S
HASH TACK IS
#LAMECOMICBOOKCHARACTERS.
THESE MIGHT BE LIKE THE FLASHER.
OR SCAT WOMAN, OR THE HUMAN
PORCH AND HIS ARCH NEM SISHES
THE WIDLER.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK.
YOU BUZZ IN WHEN YOU HAVE
ANSWERS.
>> WOLVER LISTERINE.
>> CENTRUM SILVER SURFER.
>> AQUA MAN.
>> THIS MAN KNOWS HIS AUDIENCE.
>> THANK YOU.
>> NIKKI GLASER.
>> CAT LADY.
>> POINTS, YES.
>> SENSITIVE BOYFRIEND.
>> IS THAT YOU IN THAT SWEATER?
POINTS.
>> GARFIELD.
>> THE POWER OF HATING MONDAYS.
POINT, SURE, I'LL GIVE YOU THAT.
NIKKI.
>> THE BLACK WIDOW-- IT'S LIKE A
WOMAN WHO LOST HER HUSBAND.
>> AND SHE'S AFRICAN AMERICAN.
>> YES.
>> TEAM LANTERN.
>> IT'S ON HIS PEENS OR HIS
PEENS IS SHAPED LIKE A LANT
INNER.
HIS PENIS TURNED INTO A LANTERN.
>> SOR-- HIS REAL NAME IS ZOR,
BUT HE HAS A CLIPS.